الغاز في افريقيا هو ما يتطلع اليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي للخروج بالنفق ازمه
الطاقه ولكن لماذا العين على افريقيا
طرح الاتحاد الاوروبي في وقت سابق
استراتيجيته الدوليه للطاقه للاستغناء عن
الغاز الروسي ومن ابرز البنود رفع
الواردات من الولايات المتحده واذربيجانا
ولكن الاتجاهها نحو افريقيا اكتسب اهميه
خاصه والسبب ان دول لها تتميزوا بامكان
تطوير حقول غازي جديده مع التزام الدول
الاوروبيه بالحفاظ على التعهدات بالحد من
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري والتركيز
على مصادر الطاقه المتجدده نيجيريا العضو
في منظمه الدول المصدره للنفط اوبك تعد
الاولى افريقيه والتاسعه عالميا في امتلاك
احتياطات هائله من الغاز ويمكنها ان تزود
اوروبا بالغاز بخط الانابيبها لصحراء
النيجر وهناك انجولا والكونغو وجزائر ومصر
وليبيا والم التي بدات تصدير الغاز
الطبيعي المثال للمره الاولى الى اوروبا
منتصفا نوفمبر ومن المتوقع ان يبلغ انتاج
الغاز في افريقيا ذروته عند 470 مليار
مترا مكعب بحلول العام 20 30 وفق الخبراء
تعويض بدائل الطاقه لاوروبا من افريقيا من
شانه ان يهيء وضعا جديده من الاستثمار في
مجال الغاز ويساهما بفائده كبيره للدول
الافريقيه التي تعاني غالبيتها من ازمات
اقتصاديه حاده محاسن حضاره العربيه